servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem kurzen intro video und zwar findet
heute das wohl nicht so rum wackeln das
feld treffen mit krankhafter und ein
paar anderen youtube zusammen statt
dabei werden werden wahrscheinlich 33
spielen gleich vielleicht nur minecraft
akku kraft die haben alle interesse
angemeldet wir werden auf jeden fall da
seitliche max stattfinden das alles und
jetzt mit schreiben 18 uhr heute samstag
18 uhr auf dem alexanderplatz und zwar
gibt es auf dieser welt nur die kennt
ihr wahrscheinlich mit diesem komischen
gebilde was ich so dreht ziemlich
ziemlich famous das teil ja und genau da
wollen wir uns treffen
ihr könnt auch noch öfter vorbeischauen
dich packt den link zu dem video in die
beschreibung darf das alles ein bisschen
ausführlicher gezeigt schaut euch das
video an
natürlich sagen sehen wir uns später ich
freue mich riesig bis dann